Pete thamel had a busy morning yahoo
sports senior columnist and broke the
story that Urban Meyer is stepping down
and Pete kind enough to join us Pete let
me start there maybe it's semantic
stepping down or retiring is there a
difference retiring is what it says in
the the official press release and I
think they're they're one in the same
I don't expect Obon Meyer to be a head
coach again after this and who knows
right we've spend we spent a good decade
and a half trying to crawl inside urban
miners head and you know one of most
fascinating characters I think in the
end of college football seen since the
emerged at Utah back and back in 2003
and 2004 Dan but I do think right now
the combination of his health
the combination of just going at it as
hard as he does he's really struggled
the last two years Dan with it with the
headaches from the congenital arachnoid
cyst that's in his head you know there's
been there's there's been times where he
hasn't been himself and it's not in his
DNA to become a CEO and to manage it
that way he's been 100 miles-an-hour his
entire career and I think this is a
little bit of a sign that he doesn't
feel like he can go as hard as he feels
like he needs to go it's the only way he
knows how
in three years Urban Meyer is retired on
TV or coaching again on TV I will go
with I will go with on TV some sources
told me that TV is an option i I do
think he'll stay affiliated with our
state in some way there's a real genuine
relationship with that school and with
with Gene Smith the athletic director
and you know one of his passions has
always been leadership so I wouldn't be
surprised if there's some role mentoring
coaches and such but again it's it's all
it's all very early for that but yeah
he's pretty good on TV there's any and
remember that yeah I thought he did a
good job I think right after the Rose
Bowl he'll probably work with the
mothership for the Final Four
feels like that that would be you know a
nice parting gift be able to do that and
then maybe opens the door to come back I
guess I just I'm sure I'm not surprised
that he's stepping down I'm just curious
if there's more to the story than just
health reasons
Urban Meyer I think there's I don't I
don't know you know I don't think so to
be honest with you just from the the
conversations that I've had with with
people around that program for you know
not only this I don't think this is like
a last six weeks or even six months
story I think this is a this is a
portrait of the last two years in him
not feeling like he's able to to go and
I also think it's combined with him
feeling like Bob Stoops did two years
ago when he walked away and handed it to
Lincoln Reilly the programs in good
shape the successor is the right guy
obviously Ryan de showed again against
Michigan and northwestern I think Dwayne
asking that 11 touchdown passes in his
last two games and when he does hand it
off the the infrastructure that Meier
built at Ohio State which i think is
really an important factor here dan the
Mickey Marathi at a long time strange
coach who's been with him was probably
the best in the business or certainly
one of the five best mark pan Tony's the
best recruiting director in the country
that machine's going to keep going in
and internally operations Brian Bellini
and Ryan Stamper like Myers people
basically his navin and his crew are all
going to stay in place it to keep going
and I think that's something that uh
that was important to him as he walked
away that he wouldn't be leaving he
wouldn't be leaving people in a lurch
what can you tell us about Ryan Day his
successor I did about Ryan he's a New
Hampshire guy he was recruited he you'll
appreciate this with your NBA background
and he played against Matt Bonner in
high school basketball an epic game I
wrote a story about it uh when he was
the interim earlier this year it was
like I'm gonna make it up it was like 29
28 and Ryan missed a shot at the buzzer
and if you ever I'm Matt Bonner on her
show he will talk about it with such
giddy glee but Ryan was a three point
three star three Sport athlete excuse me
in high school a plucky young offensive
coordinator named Chip Kelly recruited
Ryan to to UNH to be a quarterback he
was a complete chip was under Sean Sean
McDonald they're the longtime UNH head
coach but Ryan and chipper they are
thickest thieves and Ryan bounced around
he was a ga for Tom O'Brien at Boston
College of urban at
he worked for Al golden at temple he
worked for Steve Adagio as the oh she
attend and Don Brown work Oh oh she's at
Boston College he's obviously the great
Michigan defense coordinator and that
was under under Steve adagio so Ryan is
one of the considered one of the better
young offensive minds and all of
football and you'll appreciate this fun
fact he is now one of three Manchester
New Hampshire guys to be major college
head coaches he chip in Dan Mullen I
went to high school in Manchester New
Hampshire
along with Sarah Silverman and Adam
Sandler so there's your fun fact for the
day yeah I did it ten things to know
about Ryan day on Yahoo Sports if you
really want to median minutia you can go
to the old exclamation point you think
about writing a book on Ohio State
season mmm I'm not but it has certainly
been it's certainly kind of felt like
three seasons in one right yeah I mean
it's been bad yeah it's been broken up
you know you you've got your star player
retires you had what happened at the
beginning of the year
urban health at the end of the year you
blow out Michigan you're going to the
Rose Bowl nearly missed the playoffs
you got a Heisman Trophy candidate and
then the coach decides to step down
other than that yeah ya know it's there
there are a lot of people in that
building who when you know they won that
Big Ten like they were obviously excited
but they were just like taking a deep
exhale
of course now all the coaches and the
coaches are on the roads right now
recruiting visit it doesn't end in the
in the college football world but yeah
it has certainly been a wild year
there's no doubt I'll leave you with
this I know that we'll have some NFL
openings we had Lincoln Reilly on
yesterday and and he gave me the
obligatory answer the correct answer to
get to somebody on a national platform
but I said do you have an obligation to
yourself and family to listen to these
offers and he said no I have a great job
here but the next and I don't want to
say Sean McVeigh because I'm so tired of
people saying you got to find the next
Sean McVeigh can you see somebody making
that jump to the NFL can Lincoln Riley
look at that even though he grew up a
cowboy fan go into Cleveland or could he
go into Green Bay and be the next head
coach
yeah I think it raised a lot of eyebrows
at John Dorsey the Browns GM was at the
epoch title game on Saturday I'll say
this this stand to me is as ripe of a
year for the NFL to pluck a college head
coach now could be Jim Harbaugh could be
David Shaw who said no a bunch of times
over the years obviously Lincoln is the
hot guy I think eventually Jeff Brohm
will we'll get some looks at that level
but you know I agree with you there's
there's only one Shawn McVeigh and god
bless him he's been he's been awesome
there but I think that model is going to
become really popular meaning young
energetic offensive open-minded type guy
and also quarterback I in play collar
like I think it's vastly underestimated
when you hire a head coach he's also
your play caller and your quarterback
guy that like takes care of 65% of your
problem but Pete who was Sean McVeigh
before Sean MacGuyver ebuddy was looking
for that now we're looking for the next
Sean McVeigh who were we looking at or
four before Sean
well the NFL was such a dislike cycle of
retreading Marty morning wick type
people you know over and over and over
and over and over north Turner's of the
world so I just think it's great and
it's honestly I think we're gonna look
back in 10 years and be like why did it
take the NFL so long to catch up as
opposed to like why is now the you know
anyways hit a spread because that's
become my cat right term but why have
wide open offenses now become you know
what it take so long for them to become
the norm people like them fans want to
see them I mean time--as Holmes has just
been awesome now if you if your dad man
your show that draft I would have been
like that Holmes no way I mean it's that
quarterback evaluation game is hard now
which is why I think it's so important
to you know to have a guy who can handle
that position and be an actor good stuff
Pete Congrats on breaking the story we
appreciate your time Dan thank you very
much that's panthan Pete vamo Yahoo
Sports breaking the story that Urban
Meyer is retiring for more Dan Patrick
show to the audio
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]